hi i'm in a different place it's the
same map
but i was recording and
i didn't have my mic turned on so
there was nothing you could see
lexie could you please play some very
sad music very sad music right now
i made a big spiel a little sadder
actually if you could if you don't mind
please
thank you and i made this big dramatic
speech that i was going to move because
i didn't feel like i was at home
and i didn't feel shut up
and i didn't feel like i could really be
myself
by living in a hole in the ground
i put all my stuff in a box and i did a
big migration
to this new land and i found something
here
lexie and make it even sadder even
sadder
and i was so joyous because it's the
first time i found
one of these
i found a village i found a village
a beautiful hamlet full of beautiful
people
and yet all of my joy from finding that
was not put into words
because my microphone was not turned on
looks good cut that out make it sound
like a real cry no
lexie i'm going to cut this out so no
one sees it of course but
i'm going to just like heave and you add
crying in make it sound really realistic
like like create like this sound
synthesizer of my voice
using all the voice that i've had in my
videos
shouldn't take too long here we go
and all of that beautiful moments
will be lost like teardrops
in the rain it's a blade runner quote
anyway so i'm in a new place and i
built a house and you go you guys are
gonna love it
yeah well i can't lay down the bed i
can't exactly jump on the bed but i got
a roof
right pretty cool right you would have
been really impressed when i put that
together
and made it all the way over here and
found a village and found a plains and
also found
cows which i can turn into more cows
through a very scientific process that i
won't explain yeah
anyway so it's oh it's almost night you
can see uh see me sleep
i need to make a farm area because i
need to
get wheat to um
make more cows because if you didn't
know you need to feed the cows
in order for them to feel like they can
make more cows
it's very scientific process very
complicated actually oh also i learned a
trick
didn't know you could do that wait oh my
god
i thought it would be lit in my hand
anyway shut up me it's time for sleep
watch me sleep everybody
subscribe and like if you love me
pretty sleeping right the moon pretty
neat pretty neat
pretty neat i am crushed i am crushed
yes okay i still have dirt floors but
that's a problem for another day
because i need more cows because i need
more leather and then i need sugar cane
because i need more books because i need
to make an enchanting table because then
i need to
kill endermen and they're pretty tough
so i'm going to need better equipment so
i can get the ender
eyes something about
eyes i need to get from the enderman
eyeballs
so that they
there's another village over there
it's good that's not a bad thing it's a
good thing more village is more good
because you can trade with the villagers
and then they can give you stuff that
you want anyway
i'm not gonna worry about making a fence
right now i'm just gonna make straight
up
farm
yeah yeah i'm just gonna worry about one
for now because i don't even know how
much i have
glug oh my god this is gonna take
forever
uh lixian put on like some
hopeful music you know it's kind of like
new beginnings i am recording right
my mic is on correct yeah put on
something like hopeful like new
beginnings like
mistakes something that evokes the
feeling that mistakes have been made in
the past but they
they won't bog me down i won't be
stopped just because of the
inconveniences of the world around me or
the the the sins of my own
past something something really really
like
heartwarming and fulfilling soul bonding
yeah something like that something like
that
all right sticks
nice you like this don't are you gonna
[ __ ]
you i don't know if you can trample my
stuff
which if you can don't
oh look i got an achievement that i've
already gotten before
oh i'm out well that's
you gonna trample okay he's not
trampling you ain't trampled you
couldn't trample if you wanted
trample what i will need a fence for is
to put these cows
into now i'm not exactly sure how to
move
a cow
so i'm gonna i'm gonna experiment with
different cow
pushing techniques
cat be careful there's a ravine kitty
cat
you want a a steak steak kitty cat no
don't run please i want to be your
friend
stay cat please eat the steak
doesn't want a steak stupid cat doesn't
want my steak
what was wrong with it i'm a friendly
guy right
i'm friendly again okay i think this
might be
just enough or just not enough and then
i will be very upset
ah damn it not enough all right whatever
it's good enough for now i'm going to
make
fence fence and bada bing bada boom okay
that'll be good
that'll be good fence six defense plenty
of fence doing doing doing point
doink doing doing doing doing doink
doink i need a gate doink doink doink
doing
that'll be the cow paddock i think
that's the proper use for paddock lexian
put up the definition for paddock
p-a-d-d-o-c-k uh i need a
gate gate no gate
there we go and then i'm just gonna push
them
no there we go then i'm just gonna push
them
into there if i push them they should go
hey i'm eating you
i'm eating you what do you think about
that i'm eating you yeah you getting
there you'd be afraid
you'd be afraid of me go go
go up no no up yes yes good go and no no
no no you don't go that way go that way
yeah
yeah you want to go that way yeah you
want to go that way this is it
there's got to be a better way i don't
want to hit it because i don't want to
kill it
not yet anyway come on go in the stupid
just go go turn around go up no
go up oh my god you are just the worst
get no
you can't say no to me there we go yes
yes yes yes
perfect into the hole no this way no
oh my goodness when you want to go you
go
stop stop i will beat you i will beat
you i will win
i will win i will win i'm going to win
i'm gonna win i'm gonna win you
oh my god oh my god is the sun setting
this is a sunset have we been doing this
all day oh my god yes
yes yes you want to go that way go that
way go that way go that way
do you know do you know something's up
do you oh we're almost there we're so
close
no no stop stop we're so oh my god we're
so close
do you not like the steak do you not
like the fat oh my god
you son of a beehive
go in the yes go in the pit and then cut
you yes
yes one
all in a day's work all of the damn
time to rest my weary head all right
good
hey but a beautiful morning
now how am i gonna get two because if i
leave this open
you're gonna get out i know this i know
this about you you cannot
fool me into trusting you that face is
the face of a demon
it will not be the trade i need more
seeds yes i have more seeds
perfectly exactly as many seeds as i
need one more
bonus so those are going to grow good
onion
and i now need to get my sugar cane
going but i can i guess i can just put
it along the riverfront
that probably a better way than trying
to cultivate it myself
i don't know didn't really work before
but i don't know if there's a difference
whatever
let's try it
okay that's a lot of sugarcane and
that's gonna mean a lot of paper for me
which is good cause that's what i need
to make an enchanting table
of which i have and i think i'm just
gonna
what if i what if i got layers on this
thing
my genius is about to astound you watch
this
i need more wood no i don't
yes yes
no yes
then door watch my genius
no door
oh my god fourth time's for me okay
fifth time is the one sixth time baby
uh now
i've got that double decker house of my
dreams
it's perfect and they're out in every
way
perfectly utilitarian excellent in every
possible configuration
on the genius you can say
i already know it and watch my genius is
going to expand
my genius is unbelievable my genius
i can't get in there my genius
yes this is what i needed all along
watch and be
amazed and astounded the power of my
brain
yes wait stop hold on
the power of my brain is immense alexian
cue the
really inspirational incredible music oh
shhh
hold on that music hold on to the music
hold the music all the music
and boom yes
yes this is truly what it means
to go even further beyond not many
people know
the scope of my immense big brain
i've done it
[Music]
i've done it is this grown yet i'm
really just stalling for time for this
to grow
also um i'm gonna create the perfect um
it's gonna be like a wizard's tower you
know it's gonna be like a wizards tower
not very big yet but it'll be huge so
the enchanting table is going to be
right smack in the middle
yeah and then the bookshelves are going
to be
around it which means that i need like a
platform
oh wait
i don't fall off if i hold crouch
it seems like that would have been
pertinent information for me to know
interesting about that oh i need to do a
one back um
good thing that doesn't break when i
make it really good thing really good
thing
okay so i just needed one more back
because otherwise the front is going to
get in the way
that's okay it looks more toweresque if
it's like this
all the knowledge swirling around
it's gonna be incredible this will be
something spectacular
this will be beyond anything i've ever
known anyway is this grown yet
oh my goodness do i have bone meal oh my
goodness this is
this isn't painful i have three bones
okay i'm gonna grow some of these so
that i can
doing no what wait
is that full grown it's a full grown
that wasn't full grown okay you thank
you
you thank you you
thank you and then you
thank you you you yeah there you go
you oh thank you thank you
all right cool so i'm thinking what i'm
thinking is that if i hold this out
they're gonna like it i think that's a
thing i'm pretty sure that's the thing
well this is infinitely easier this is
incredibly easier
oh but you're also but you're going to
want to get back in
hi hi hey come here hey come on you know
you
wanted come on yeah you know
you know yeah you know yeah oh yeah oh
yeah okay
all right oh come on in come on in yep
uh-huh uh-huh
let me just close the door and then
actually let me get outside
i don't want to be in the splash zone
you yes that's it
oh do it again they can't do it again
give me one no you're too young for that
it worked guys guys and gals it worked
it worked it worked it did it i've done
it
and then i will slaughter them for their
leather
hey hey how you doing hey good to see
you oh look at these cows trapped on the
other side i'll rescue you
be careful there's monsters about you
wouldn't want to be near the
monsters would you yeah that's right hey
come on this way
yeah come with me you guys can swim
right
can they swim is this gonna drown them
please don't let this drop i don't want
this to happen
if they drown oh they they can swim
oh yeah come on they're so slow
come this way there's plenty of room in
the paddock
plenty of room in the paddock plenty of
room
plenty of room in the paddock plenty of
room in the paddock
plenty of room come on there's plenty of
room no don't fight come on share
if you both squeeze it once you can't
get in the paddock
gotta back off so one can get it can you
okay good that's fine cause you're gonna
eat
and you're gonna eat and then you're
gonna make babies you're gonna eat
you're gonna eat and you're gonna make
babies
yeah as i get experience from it too
excellent
excellent all right so i just need to
make the paddock bitter a bit bitter
bigger
bigger cat
cat be my friend hello
you want steak oh you don't like steak
okay whatever all right bedtime
well i've really done it
i've really done it this time i feel
good
i feel accomplished my lumbar is doing
incredibly sleeping in that bed
oh god bones i'm gonna get bone meal
yeah yeah stay away from my cows
only i can kill my cows you can't yeah
try me try me
with this last arrow i die pathetically
let's see if i can build a bigger
paddock
oh my god demon this floating dirt
certainly can sustain the weight of a
giant cow
oh my god hush your dumb faces
this probably is what it is i'm not 100
sure but if i do
make the paddock a bit bigger
they should be able to go in right okay
and i do have bone so i can make more
bone meal so i can grow more crops
perfect love it back up back up
back up messy and i gotta open this give
me more room to roam i guess you know i
did make that
kind of small at first anyway oh god no
no no no no no no you come no
no no this way hey hey hey
idiot dummy come on get in here
that's right that's what i'm talking
about that's what i've that's what i was
previously discussing and there's no
wheat oh
where do we go oh it's so stupid all
right where'd those cows go
there they are hey come on you come here
you
come here moo come here moo
uh you use for sheep use it
hello no there just woke up oh yeah i
forgot
i'm a cow an existential crisis it's my
entire life's purpose just to supply
this crazy man leather
yeah yeah it is and i'm not going to
lead you any farther because you
don't need to go any farther but i need
you and i need you
hello come along couch okay
we got new visitors everybody back up
back up back up back up
come on there's plenty of oh it really
was they were just stuck it really was
a case where they were just too stupid
to figure out you know what i'm just
gonna
open her up you you come on in you know
what
hey hey hey hey hey come on come on dad
you know you want to okay who who who
needs
who needs you you okay
yeah all right and there you go okay and
then
nice let me put the gate here
boink
i'm the mad farmer i've gone insane
oh that's not gonna stay i need to fill
it up with water first luge
lunge flash okay
good moo i
don't care
all right
all right hey you guys stay happy
all right this is good i think this is
great and then i'll be up on my wizards
tower
looking over at my crops and my cows and
soon the pigs
i'm soon the sheepies and soon the
horses
i will all be mine all right i think
this more than makes up for the fact
that i
screwed up that last recording so yay
i'm here now
home is over there somewhere you can see
the little tower i made on that mountain
but his
original home way over there nether
portal i'll get to that later
i almost regret making a new thing for
the nether which didn't seem to be worth
it but i'm gonna
start journeying towards the end of the
game
now i'm gonna beat this because i've
never beat it
anyway thank you everybody so much for
watching check out more videos that i've
made
on my channel of which you're on hey
have you checked out a heist with
markiplier yet
that's some good stuff if you haven't
you're missing out
it's quality content and hey there might
be a sequel coming
but only if you liked the video and
subscribe
no i'm just kidding maybe thank you and
as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you